welcome back to new rock stars this is
the boys underground where we talk about
amazon's darkest horrific live-action
superhero show i'm jessica clemens here
with me today is tommy beckham finally
hi guys welcome finally
and marina
mata back we're back again that's right
we're talking about the boys right it
took two years
yeah it took a very long time but also
well worth it i'm happy to be in the
middle of this
i'll just sit here and look you guys
both in the eyes
i'm very excited i'm very excited to
hang out with these two people not
excited to talk about this episode
because uh
like it or not all is probably lost and
homelander is still the center of
everything and his success
is only rising in episode five and
there's only about three or two episodes
left we still haven't reached herogasm
which is the episode everyone's looking
forward to but
enough of me trying to get into this
heartbreaking story let's have tommy do
the recap i'd love to this episode
completely revolves around homelander
what a bastard
now that stan edgar is gone homelander
has placed ashley to fill his position
and as expected he has no idea how to
run a big corporation he's really kind
of inept at it but it doesn't matter
because he can melt people with his face
and his insecurities begin to kick in he
also appointed the deep the head of
crime analytics
yeah that's the man that can talk to
fish
oh god it's all just bad this whole
episode is like
this is the always lost episode however
not all is lost
green mave supplies butcher with some
more temp compound v
maeve not only gets drunk with butcher
but they get it on oh yeah my god
i was so mad at that scene i kept
thinking one of them i kept thinking she
was gonna die i don't know why the boys
has me oh is he still super at that
point well the boys has me traumatized
where i just think at any point someone
could die shockingly and i'm like
wouldn't it be crazy
if they sleep together and then she dies
immediately i thought she was gonna kill
him by crushing him yeah
butcher he's he's a tortured soul but he
still gets asked somehow homelander
immediately finds out that maeve has
been talking to butcher because he can
smell him on her which i guess kind of
makes sense right he's so he orders
black noir to capture her everyone is
afraid of homelanders and that includes
me kimiko is recovering from her
injuries in the hospital frenchie when
she realizes the powers she once had are
completely gone we gotta figure that out
in glee they both dance to i got rhythm
by judy garland that is until nina finds
frenchie and orders him to kill a family
that's nice really yeah it's a real
uplifting episode yeah when he doesn't
show she comes back for him leaving
chemical in the hospital alone and
heartbroken
yikes soulja boy has made his way to
america and probably kills 19 people by
exploding near a coffee shop when he
hears russian music which triggers his
horrid memory of being tortured for
almost 40 years kind of understanding
understandable completely understandable
in the world of the boys that's one of
the more uh
justifiable
a lot has changed for him wait till he
finds iphones but oh my god on the
search to see the crimson countess after
grabbing his superhero suit from the
legend paul ryser i love it he crushed
him he's so proud of him so good he was
uh he's like an amazon darling he was on
uh what red oaks for a couple of seasons
oh he's so good former vp of hero
management at fought and a like a lot of
hubris like
i love the human non-powered characters
that are like feel like they're
invincible because it's so great i mean
we have a character who can pop people's
heads by looking at them anyway
when they arrive at crimson county's
home beautiful double wide mobile
they rudely interrupt her zoom call tie
her to a chair and use her as bait to
bring in soldier boy butcher drugs mm in
order to keep him out of the way so he
doesn't ruin the mission i mean butcher
he's really heartbreaking this year
i feel like he loves mm and frenchie and
he is just he's doing a horrible way
he's burning those bridges so severely i
mean it's really it's hard to see your
weight back that's when we find out that
no one on payback truly like soldier boy
kind of a parallel to homeland and that
they handed them off to the russians for
free
so that obviously doesn't sit well
with soldier boy and his new powers so
he kills crimson countess goodbye lauren
holden from walking dead you did a great
job should have never
slept with the governor uh and now
hopefully he's in the boy's hands but
really what what
i mean guess the enemy of my enemy is my
friend but i don't know like what are we
doing here
we there's so many discussion points
that we're gonna touch on and that's
because it's clear like the ending is
just so open ended up like i don't know
what's going to happen now it just feels
like i mean like their their plan is the
basically a
more erratic homelander yeah like
they're like we'll get this even crazier
homelander to kill homeless 100
we'll see
be sure to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com where we currently
have two latest obsession shirts that's
right we're double obsessed you can grab
our obi-wan kenobi theme shirt empire's
most wanted or a miss marvel themed
shirt cosmic daydream both shirts are
limited edition and won't last long so
be sure to grab one or
treat yourself to two today and when you
purchase the latest obsession shirt you
unlock the ability to get a custom shout
out on either our obi-wan kenobi or ms
marvel after show now the obi-wan kenobi
show is wikileaks and that's a little
close to my heart so you buy a kenobi
shirt say a little something about me
i'm sick of eric getting all the [ __ ]
love sorry
sing american all the love check out all
of our awesome merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com
we also want to thank our friends at
g-fuel if you want to feel powered up
like a soup but don't want to risk
taking that compound v why not try some
g fuel instead guaranteed to not make
you hung over compound v puking
but to give you that same energy but
still lasers out of your eyes maybe
teleport become new g fuel is a
sugar-free energy drink made from
natural ingredients and it is used by
ufc fighters esport athletes
bodybuilders skateboarders youtube stars
fitness models and even nfl players so
basically everyone there's over 20
unique and delicious flavors to choose
from i like the pineapple it's like a
bahama mama i don't know what it i call
it i love it it's so good and while g
fuel does contain caffeine they do offer
a caffeine free g-fuel hydration formula
so
if you're new to g fuel or already a fan
of the product you can use our link
g-fuel dot l-y new rockstar to get 10
off your g-fuel order while supporting
our channel that's 10 off your order of
g-fuel using our link in the description
gfuel.ly
new rockstars
something we like to do here is talk
about some of the missible details in
this episode because i know that you
guys are wondering what they are and i'm
here to break them down for you this
episode's title the last time to look on
this world of lies is also the title of
volume 10 issue 4 in the comics and they
do share somewhat of resemblance but
ultimately they don't uh this comic is
two years in butcher's life and how
great he's feeling how phenomenal it is
until his wife dies a super blue hawk is
a creation for the show and does not
appear in the comics blue hawk was
getting his own law enforcement show if
you guys remember it's called red white
and blue justice and it's about just
normal civilians patrolling with him
which honestly is the worst idea you
could ever ever make um and also if you
want to call blue hawk a superhero uh
best character of the episode in my
opinion and i think it does also in your
guys is the legend played by paul reiser
yes he is in the comics of straight
comics to screen the legend was one of
the boy sources for intel on va and
soups because he used to work at victory
comics a division of vod american he
also had a prosthetic leg in the comics
which he loved to show in this episode
um if you missed it i bet you didn't sir
comes a lot 779 is seth rogen yep and he
is also using starlight's wishlist oh my
god
hated that scene hated every moment of
it
something to add that in the comics
butcher maeve never actually hooked up
though maeve did help him get intel from
the vaught headquarters by getting like
cameras in just sending intel and
neither soulja boy and crimson countess
were also in a relationship they were
just partners uh they put both those
into the storyline just for the show
which i think is a good thing to keep in
mind uh when you're coming down or when
you're coming down
from that compound v but when you're
getting into it you're gonna be like oh
i need to know why they do this in the
comics they're not in love in the comics
neither of those people neither of those
things happen so let's get into the big
questions
why did vots sell soldier boards to the
russians i think it's because they knew
they had homelanders like they were like
we've got like we don't need soulja boy
anymore we haven't a representative of
like the american dream truth justice in
the american way and people hated
soldier boy and they at this point they
did not yet hate homeland that is true i
was thinking that because it was like
you have
like soldier boy who's like let's say
soldier boys like patient zero and then
it's like oh we found all the flaws of
patient zero maybe we can make a better
version of him and then they did
homelander and now they're like another
mistake they're just going to keep
trying to rewrite their mistakes with
more soups we can do this again it's
fine it's okay we'll fire another one
this one however this one won't have
insecurities uh because it does seem
like you're giving too much power to a
horrible person you know and but he was
easily captured that's the weird thing
yeah they just well i mean they had help
right they were tipped off so they knew
exactly how to get them and they
obviously had that whatever weapon it
was that could subdue him i'm guessing
is the same thing that he used on kimiko
that can like dampen power well what i
think it is is well first off i think
that
the team helped yeah this game helped
escort him away but they did talk about
in this episode when they were watching
the montage video of what they did to
soldier boy that like
not terrigen but like that gas knocks
him out so i wonder if they use that gas
on him on the field and knocked out like
a lot of people but also knocked out him
as well i mean vot could have been the
ones that said like this is the only
thing that knocks them out here's this
gap
oh my god i like the way that they were
giving compound v to uh
people in the middle east to try and
create yeah i also think it gives more
leeway to like how
when uh what's her name the leader of it
was like why would they send you goons
you super goons you're not doing
anything it's like well we're here to
actually help and it's like we're not
actually here to help we're actually
here to send off a superhero it's a part
of our plan we just need to get away a
problematic guy yeah yeah and why
does it i think we know but like why
does everyone hate soldier i think he's
a real piece of [ __ ]
i think i think he's really awful my
theory douchebag yeah yeah i think he's
like he's like his winter soldier
amnesia kind of like slow brain now
makes him almost sympathetic where
you're like come on bud catch up to the
2020s but i think back in his heyday he
was just awful yeah and he seemed awful
like i need to know what those montages
that motors milk is having with him
involved in and then because it goes
from that to him doing a horrible
redemption of rapture by blondie and i
love that song i love that song me and
my mom sing that song and then when we
both watched it she was like he
butchered it five five fridays that was
everybody's jive i was like stop him
stop him yeah that was bad stop him
but that was so bad it was good it was
so yeah i kind of want to make it my
ringtone
what's so also what's his plan now was
is he gonna start taking out all the
people that is is he gonna come after
black noir next i don't yeah it's crazy
because like
butcher thinks he somehow has like
control over him now and i'm like i
don't think anyone has control over this
guy no
well maybe
he still has the insecurities that um
that homelander does have because he's
he really was in love with crimson
county yeah and so maybe it's like he is
looking for the same thing of like why
does everybody hate me yeah yeah i
didn't know everybody hated me
i mean definitely his when he was
walking along i think it's just a road
in new york and he saw like dawn of the
seven and like homeland he was like the
[ __ ] like he was like so how dare they
matt yeah like he wasn't pleased and
like so he's gone to get a super suit
he's also he's obviously like wanting to
get back into that and he's he's not
planning on staying hidden
he's
awesome i was like how did billy butcher
and hughie beat
uh soldier boy two crimson kids but then
i was like he doesn't know the subway
yeah he doesn't know how to use people
how to get a taxi like he's calling
they left all the b-roll of after he
killed 19 people he'd run into the red
line
it was like the red light's different
what the [ __ ] he's looking at a map
actually honestly maybe that's still the
same from the 70s though than new york
but i was i was like how could i was
like why did they get there first and
then i was like no he probably was just
no he was confused what is this on the
plus side and that was i like that that
look of like he's been he hasn't been to
new york in like 40 years and he is
straight up so lost and confused he
looks so disheveled and just a ragged
man
and so like he i i but i did like it's
still
not to be like the 70s were great i'm
like he was still like from the 70s not
from the like 1910s yeah like not
everything's so crazy he's like yeah i'm
not surprised technology advanced but
like holy crap probably just like
annoyed and like looking at stuff and
being like oh oh oh oh he's just a
cranky old man in the young man's body
yeah yeah what is all this
turn that off is that russian music
um
god soldier boy is
we'll get more into him too a little bit
but i also want to know what you guys
think oh wait yes well i was going to
say he got a suit he's he's coming back
just to
get the people who wronged him and then
probably headed to vaught yeah
and how are they gonna i mean like
they're clearly gonna try and yeah well
they're gonna try and like receive him
and spin it right like they're gonna be
like soldier boys yeah
or they're gonna be like soldier boys
compromised in this rush is a russian
asset my
favorite things that could possibly
happen is that they this build up to
soldier board meeting homelander and
homelanders slices him in half
it's just nothing you just don't yeah
nothing i am still about the fact that i
think butcher or my mom is like the sun
has to do something the sun is the only
one yeah so butcher this sun soulja boy
it's just a just like a mirror for you
that would be honestly very funny it
would be amazing if they set that whole
thing up and then homelander just goes
he's like
a oh this old man
um who are the people that nina wants
killed i tried looking into it could not
find any information about uh pieter
pietro simenov um and his daughter
katrina but i'm assuming they're
probably politicians yeah and it's weird
like you know like frenchie's like i
don't want to do this and she's like
you've done it before you killed a kid
god how awful was frenchie like what
what
was he or was she just referring to how
he wasn't there when the kids got killed
[Music]
oh that's right yeah which i was like
damn everyone's giving him such a hard
time and he's giving himself such a hard
time i was like your friend was od
no he didn't just like right don't get
an ice cream right right yeah it was
like nina's gonna be i want nina to be a
bigger person or a bigger part than she
is right now yeah and that's why i think
when i said uh last time we were here in
the comics vaught gave katrina some bad
compound v to inject and people to stage
a coup in russia and then vaught
betrayed her and blew up all the people
with the compound
and was like we've saved russia so i
really think that storyline could still
apply to katrina with what she's doing
right now and so maybe she know you mean
oh nina sorry yeah
with nina right now and i think that
like she was easily it was easy to find
um soldier boy in russia because she's
the one harboring him yeah he's like
yeah my people were the one that took
him from bot we're working with vaught i
work closely with vaught yeah um and
that's also why i'm like
it's so easy for uh what i'm called to
give out compound v that's also why um
yeah she just like has maybe she's like
do they just get it from a vending
machine i bought i don't i thought it
was hard to get it i don't know i know
some nurses that are like pretty loose
with prescription meds you want some
vicodin baby maybe it's like that you
just go in the supply closet i mean i
thought about that when she came back
with more i was like damn they're just
handing this out this is candy to you
but she is super so it's like all right
she could just like open a lot
of yeah
so uh uh if
you're saying like nina is the one who
actually her people are the one holding
soldier boy or they were right
maybe um the people that she wants
killed
the kyoto or whatever his name is
what if that guy that she once killed is
the scientist who came up with the
weapon
that disables suits oh
nice so she wants to
have only one weapon in existence and
that being soldier boy because now it's
in him or whatever he care bear stairs
everybody
so then what if it's like okay i don't
want anybody else to be able to get this
weapon so i'm gonna kill this the
scientist who
who invented it maybe and then maybe the
daughter also knows yeah or maybe it's
just like for good measures
i love that and also
nina the best time to be doing that the
homelander does not know what he's doing
with vaughn right he is so confused
she's like she could be laying down the
like the pieces to start taking over
more places because she's just like
edgar's gone now so and if soldier boy
can eliminate everybody else's
superpowers then he would be the only
one left if she doesn't know about uh
ryan
so then he would be the only if he just
goes care bears derek
okay so i think we can assume that
nina's gonna be playing a bigger part
yeah that she's gonna she's the domino
the lead domino
okay what happened to queen maeve
she's not a rehab no she's not a she's
just in like a like a holding cell like
was it black noir i didn't like it i
paused it
also it's it's black noir getting his
payback yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the same holding cell that like
starlight was in last season yeah
exactly that's exactly what i was making
a stronger one a different one yeah but
i'm scared that she actually got like
beat up because it's like i'm sure
homelander was like do whatever you want
yeah i thought he was gonna kill her i
really thought like i don't know why
maeve to me is like i'm always she's
such a tortured tragic figure because
she was on the plane with him when they
killed him so you're always kind of like
eventually she kind of has to die in the
show i think she's going to
i think that i think she's like that's
why i'm still thinking even if we see
her in the jail sale she's going to be
very weak she's going to be like broken
because i'm sure black noir went off
yeah
but he can't but he'll mother can't kill
her yet because it's like okay someone
he just killed alex uh this speedy guy
super he just killed super sonic so then
if maeve immediately does it's like well
what's happening yes and she's like an
og member
so he probably feels like he can't he
would lose points or the seven would
like go down in status and she
represents the lgbt portion and she's
like a recovering alcoholic so people
are like constantly looking up to her
she will always be she has a good decent
size of like fans she doesn't care
but she's she's there i was actually
really sad this episode when she when
butcher was like yeah i've been sober
for four years and then got her to drink
i was like she was doing good i know i
was like what would you do
he's such a piece of [ __ ] this year he
is
he and he's like i hate to do this like
freaking
like uh stupid movie trope thing but
like he's bringing everyone down with
him with sadness like he is
intentionally forcing everyone to be sad
he's burning
yeah
he's a mess i'm the only
like okay part i have with butcher right
now is that like a monologue he went
into when he was like all super bad he
was like even you yeah he was like
they're all bad you guys are just
ticking time bombs like you all need to
be stopped and i was like my my mom
called me and she was like he's right
and she's like she's right he was right
he's right my mom called about something
i will say after our question actually
no i'll say not because i didn't add it
my mom called and said
mother milk has powers and i think
that's why he's taking his medication
all the time and all these triggers that
he's getting in his mind are because his
powers are starting to come back and he
doesn't remember that
she thinks that the what happened with
soldier boy is that he he his powers
released killed his family and soldier
boy was the one there when he woke up
and he thinks soulja boy is the reason
that his family is dead that's actually
mother's military oh god that's my mom
you're a mom on this show
get on here
that's my mom's theory and she was like
she he has to be at this point and i was
like that'd be really cool if it happens
my mom loves the show you guys shout out
to linda yeah
next we need to know a question that's a
hot topic
will kimiko ever get her powers back i
think so she doesn't want them though i
know and i don't want it that's why i
think she'll get him back
the show doesn't do anything right by
anyone well if you want something it's
going to go opposite she'll get them
back when she needs them the most do you
think she's going to take compound v
again to get it back oh maybe to save
only to say frenchie right no yeah no no
she's not just going to shoot up for fun
it's going to be like at a very dire
moment between frenchie and homelander
and she's gonna be like i have to shoot
up yeah i have to shoot up
i was
her happiness of like hand me this thing
i can't pick up
i know but you're right that is why
they're going to give that back to you
she's for sure guys so we need her
unfortunately we need all the help we
can and
i hate to say it but you go
you shoot up now chemical we need you
right now get back out there your boy's
missing
it's like a quarterback that like breaks
his leg and they shouldn't record his
own they're like get up get out of here
yeah
finish the job
you're our gun
so chemical will probably end up getting
their powers back
you guys after this horrible
horrible episode what's the plan now
soldier boys loose chemical lost their
powers maeve is missing the deep got rid
of the entire crime department
huey's high off compound v and also
spotted at the scene where soldier boy
blew up an entire coffee shop yeah it's
and starlighted him probably broke up
again
yes they did
the scene i don't like that the scene
was in the middle where maeve and
butcher were talking about like we could
do this no we could do this no because
we literally leave the episode with that
it's like we don't know what's gonna
happen now we're assuming soulja boy is
gonna help yeah yeah he it seems like he
is yeah yeah he's mad enough right like
that's true yeah at least for now and
then he'll go off and do his own thing
but temporarily and they're stupid
because that's my that's my fear is like
they're like i understand this is our
last option yeah but you're also all
your eggs are in the basket of hoping
soldiers will even listen to person
actually i thought the same thing when
he was blasting out of the uh russian
like yeah
it seemed like an unintentional like he
was just like
i can't have as like a response like
yeah yeah because he got he got like
triggered essentially ptsd like he had
all those flashbacks at the truck and
then oh the poor russian guy who was
like hey minnie you want some help
he literally and then the shot if you
watch it again you see his skin
deteriorated
is why i'm afraid that he doesn't know
how to control it yeah and he's only
gonna be like they're gonna start
fighting i'm waiting for that because
there's a i think it's a beach but we
see him using his power or he's like
fighting someone with butcher in the
trailer and i'm like i don't think he
knows how to use his power and they're
they're like up front with homelander
and he's like i can't do it
you can't do it i don't know how to do
it yeah
it's gonna be he pulls a hulk where he's
like come on
come on he's gonna keep hitting himself
this episode is ridiculous we hope that
it goes i hope that actually honestly
episode six has to resolve yeah what
we're confused about at the end of this
a little bit give us something give us
something starlight start breaking stop
breaking up with huey yeah i'm on huey's
side in this at this point uh
unfortunately because i'm like
yeah that's our last option dude you
were dating this horrible man i was also
like like yeah he was horrible but like
or i mean yeah soldier boy was horrible
and they don't want to they don't want
to team up with him and i can understand
why mother's milk refuses to team up
with him but in that scene at the end to
for starlight i was like but why though
she i think she's doing that thing where
it's like he murdered 19 innocent people
and i'm like
you don't know that it wasn't
intentional and also how many people
have you accidentally murdered well yeah
she was like you're teaming up with the
murderer and i was like you he killed a
bunch of people
that's you your man
he punched a hole through first yeah
exactly exactly speaking of punching
holes through people yes i have the kill
count if you guys want it yes i do need
it it's very simple this week uh
all the all the kills belong to soldier
boy
yep all of them so he exacto knifes a
scientist while he's sticking it
in his eyeball he grabs it and he goes
and then he looked away at that seat i
forgot that it like it came back yeah
yeah he he yanked it out and he was like
this is what you get
uh he explodes but i think by accident
on the streets of new york killing 19
people and then he blows up crimson
countess in her trailer
so the number of kills for this episode
is 21 and they all go to our very
handsome very fit
shaggy did you hear him give the
interviewer he's like
i got in great shape to play soldier boy
and then they were like you could have
just had them make your costume yes i
talked about it last week because i was
like that's so goofy he i felt so bad
but he also that comes so sad well he
made it out of that uh jar oh he's naked
yeah yeah
he's fine he's fine and he did great
we had we got to compare your butt to
huey's butt yeah and i was like he has a
nice butt but your butt was a fit button
yeah he did that for himself let's be
honest oh god he was like they were like
we don't have to we paid you to act and
he was like no no no no
no look at that
the saddest part is refuse to do this
episode i'm not even going to say words
just show my show my ass that's my
that's the tagline show
um
i am honestly a little sad and
heartbroken that we won't get the
crimson
song about april anymore i know our
beautiful
theme park
that performances park was crazy
they had the real people like when you
go to the theme park it's all these
people dressed up like the people that
play it was like the real crimson cap
with lights but i was like
where she's using she's like you want
the anal beads and she lights it on fire
warming them up so they're not cold for
her [ __ ]
yeah that's fair
when she did that i was like what's
going on
the first episode the first 12 minutes
but this episode absolutely not uh that
part but also when butcher tackles her
uncle
so broke it's like where'd you go what's
happening that's right yes
that's right
seth rogen to the i don't understand it
you said he wrote it jesus
of it yeah
you know that he was like i want to be
the viewer
i'm going to be the webcam creek
give me that starlight lotion you guys
that was actually the point the episode
of this breakdown of the episodes
that was this breakdown of the episode
five of the boys underground with me
marina mastros
tommy bechtol
and oh my gosh it's coming back we're
gonna keep doing this every friday after
we watch an episode and you guys are
also gonna be triggered with us and with
soldier boarding and essentially
triggered by anal beads that are too big
they're too hot too hot
huge they were it was bowling balls on a
string on dental floss i said girl
settle
whatever he's paying you is not enough i
know it
anyway it was 19 a minute
uh follow us at new rockstars here on
youtube and all social media platforms
make sure to hit that notification bell
so you get all the alerts when we're
getting into action
be sure to check out the new rockstars
discord server and don't forget about
our tumblr that jessica is constantly
updating doing great work on tumblr
she's going crazy over on tumblr so be
sure to check it out
and that's it for the boys underground
check us out next week
[Music]
[Music]
you